from swashbuckling swordplay to
supernatural sorcery Netflix as a trove
of hidden fantasy treasures just waiting
to be discovered you may have seen the
big titles on the streaming service like
Pirates of the Caribbean or Stardust but
that's just the edge of the map as far
as Netflix as fantasy selection is
concerned we're heading into uncharted
lands to seek out the best Netflix
fantasy films you should be watching
legend of the nagas pearls centuries
after an ancient war between two races
one descendant of the losing race
discovers a way to restore their former
glory through mystical objects known as
the Naga pearls that's the start of the
action-packed adventure in Legend of the
Naga pearls which sees a common street
thief and his CGI animal sidekick caught
in the middle of the battle to take
possession of the mystical objects
whoever ends up with them could change
the fate of the world if that all sounds
convoluted and ridiculous don't worry it
is but it's also a ton of fun for anyone
who enjoys martial-arts fantasy in all
its CG heavy wire fighting Beauty Cirque
des freak the vampires assistant if
we're all being honest with ourselves
Cirque des freaked the vampires
assistant looks downright horrible from
that overblown name to a release poster
that looks like a student film parody of
Twilight there is nothing about this
movie that would entice you to hit play
but anyone who does give it a chances in
for a treat with a diverse cast that
includes john c reilly Salma Hayek
Willem Dafoe and Josh Hutcherson the
vampires assistant is a bizarre mix of
fantasy horror and comedy that offers
one of the more original vampire movies
of late I am so excited to be here an
anonymous small town which used to have
character but is now just a bland suburb
filled with chain stores and surrounded
by slums after two friends sneak into a
traveling freak show in their hometown
one of them becomes convinced that one
of the performers is a real vampire that
fateful night leads to the two friends
joining a secret vampire war even that
description sounds terrible but vampires
assistant pulls it off well enough to
make for a unique viewing experience
yeah fill that hole
I'm all cramped up my legs are still
gone can you feel this
Wow dragon heart battle for the heart
fire somehow like the slow creep of a
respiratory infection
the 1996 fantasy adventure movie dragon
heart quietly became a franchise maybe
it's because we live in a magical world
or maybe it's just because Studios love
them some sequels but there are now four
dragon heart movies
they all follow the same basic premise a
dragon shares a heart with a human and
through their bond they save a kingdom
or something equally important
fortunately you don't need to catch up
on any of the other sequels to
understand what's happening in 2017 s
dragon heart battle for the heart fire
the 2017 prequel to the original film
sees a king pass away leaving his dragon
without a heart buddy it turns out that
the King had two estranged grandchildren
though who go to war with each other
over the throne add-in Patrick Stewart
as the voice behind the dragon and
you'll be surprised just how much fun
you have with it friend I like the sound
of that
Mojang The Lost Legend equal parts
archaeological adventure and
supernatural epic mojin The Lost Legend
follows three grave robbers who are
hired by a shadowy cult leader to search
for the tomb of an ancient princess to
reach the tomb they'll have to use their
wits to make it through a series of
increasingly dangerous challenges you
won't find many critics praising mo Jin
The Lost legend but don't let that steer
you away while the plot may be
bare-bones and the characters fairly
one-dimensional there's a lot of fun to
be had in these underground catacombs as
wave after wave of supernatural terror
descends on her protagonists if you get
a kick out of archaeologist kung fu
fighting undead demons you're bound to
have a good time with this movie Solomon
Kane the story of a bloodthirsty pirate
who turns to a life of peace after the
devil tries to claim his soul Solomon
Kane is a rare combination of action
supernatural thrills and fantasy that
doesn't get too bogged down in the
spectacle
not yet ready for hell Cain fights hell
spawn demons and regular bad guys in
equal measure
but grounds the action with quieter
glimpses into his own struggle to change
his ways critics found plenty to like
about the movie even if audiences barely
gave it a second glance The Monkey King
- while the first Monkey King is
enjoyable the sequel is where the story
really comes to life following the
simian deity as he protects a traveling
monk from supernatural threats don't get
us wrong everything about these movies
is cheesy but The Monkey King - loads
that cheesiness with better visuals
better pacing and a better overall story
than its predecessor making it a must
watch for anyone looking for pure
unrestrained fantasy adventure and true
to form for these kinds of Chinese
productions the climactic battle is a
visual jumble of ridiculous CGI that
alone makes this movie worth the price
of admission and since that admission
price is zero to begin with what do you
have to lose
psychokinesis in just a few short years
director Yeon sang hos train to Busan
has become a modern zombie classic with
that kind of pedigree you'd think that
his 2018 fantasy superhero mashup
psychokinesis would have made more waves
but sadly it slipped under the current
for most people when a despondent
security guard unknowingly drinks water
tainted by some sort of mystical meteor
juice he suddenly gains the power to
move things around with his mind with
his newfound abilities he sets out to
reconnect with his estranged daughter
while it takes a while to get going
psychokinesis rewards viewers with an
epic finale that makes the whole journey
worthwhile and proves again that yeon is
a skilled behind the camera as he is at
writing heartfelt emotional stories
vanishing time a boy who returned for a
twisted mind-bending fantasy experience
look no further than vanishing time a
boy who returned this south korean film
opens with five children who stumble on
a mysterious cave deep in the forest
where they find a magical egg at the
bottom of a lake according to local
legend the egg holds a monster that can
devour time when the kids decide to
break open the egg they unleash an
unexpected supernatural force that
changes each and every one of them while
the central premise of vanishing time
has its basis in fantasy the story that
plays out afterward is a remarkably
gripping drama about friendship trust
and betrayal it's a quieter more brutal
take on the fantasy genre but it's just
as gripping as any
action-packed spectacle you're likely to
find on Netflix give it a chance and you
won't be disappointed
The Imaginarium of Doctor Parnassus the
story of a traveling troupe of
performers led by a man who's made a bet
with the devil to see who can collect
the most Souls The Imaginarium of Doctor
Parnassus is a unique fantasy adventure
that most mainstream audiences missed in
2009 Imaginarium straddles a thin line
between magical surrealism and
over-the-top goofiness but to its credit
it never goes too far in either
direction Heath Ledger does a lot to
keep the film grounded even as it goes
deeper and deeper into dreamlike
territory
if you missed Imaginarium when it was
first released you should definitely
give it a shot now that it's on Netflix